[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum hey thanks for
listening ryan it's a joy always looking
at you
that's nice thank you you're going out
of town so um yes we're getting some
work done today we're doing a couple of
episodes today a couple ads a couple of
yeah no
news better break
yeah that's true
uh
what's gonna say hey thanks for making
our podcast your podcast this week um i
know there's a lot of choices out there
but you made ours your choice and we
appreciate that if you really liked this
episode if you're a big kitty lots fan
we urge you to give the podcast another
chance listen to it if you liked it why
not he's like wow that was a really fun
interview i really liked that interview
well
let's give it one more chance
uh tell us the uh handles that you could
follow us on right
inside of you pod on twitter inside to
be podcast on instagram and facebook
that's correct that's correct so follow
us uh there's an inside of you online
store you can get cool merch autographs
all that stuff there's uh my band
sunspin you go to sunspin.com for band
merch and all that stuff
i'm going to be going to some cons july
10th 11th and 12th i'll be in illinois
metropolis the superman celebration tom
welling and i will be there in illinois
metropolis illinois is really a place
goldman travel as well i've driven
through it yeah yeah it's off um what is
that highway interesting
but it's not too far from where i grew
up i don't think i drove from nashville
back to california through that way
really yeah it's fun let's get a little
trick
yeah illinois
i hung out with margo kidder in
metropolis illinois one year we gambled
together god rest her soul
but we're going to be doing the
smallville nights supposedly we've
already sold a whole bunch of tickets so
people are going to come see us do a
show a two-man show
which is a lot of fun it's called
smallville nights on saturday night june
11th and i'll be signing june 11th and
12th as will tom and then we're off to
australia australia yeah down under mate
so if you want to get our tickets to
come see us
uh we'll be signing autographs and doing
shows
uh june 18th
and also in sydney and then june 25th in
perth both those weekends
and small nights and all that stuff so
if you're around also become one of my
lovable patrons
join patreon
uh they support the podcast i love them
they give back in many ways and there's
like different tiers and you can get all
sorts of cool perks and merch and
go to patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n.com
inside of you and i will message you
back after you join i hope you become a
patron
anyway let's get into this episode uh i
thought it was really fun
i really loved uh
talking with katie lotz yeah uh i liked
her a lot
she uh i bet you have i bet you've heard
that one haven't you katie uh it was
really fun she was very open and uh i've
been trying to get her for a while and
our schedules didn't match up
and we finally got her in-house
right here in front of me
it was it was a good time didn't you
enjoy her she was great she was she was
really fun she's sarcastic she's smart
we talk about her directing her her life
uh we get personal we always do so
without further ado
let's get into katie let's get inside of
katie lotz
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
well something happened folks if you're
listening now
you'll kind of
well katie why don't you tell them what
happened
uh the card was full
so basically we got well i think what
five minutes and then
and katie here katie lotz who i'm
talking with
she def definitely saw the director in
you
because the first thing he said well
let's just roll and let's just do it i
saw this calmness about you that it's
okay it's a problem
let's solve it let's start recording
let's do this again i could see it
because now i know because everybody's
like you know brandon was telling
brandon ralph was saying what a good
director you were
and um and i know it's something that
you really love doing now
and
who
who got you into directing what was that
what was the thing that that kind of
just where it took off
um
well i mean i guess i i shot a short
film um
called twin turbo
twin turbo yeah it was a fun thing uh
and and then that got me
into the warner brothers directing
program uh and then after that i was
able to and then i shadowed
uh james bamford
and uh and our producing director kevin
mock um and then i directed for one of
the episodes of legends of tomorrow
what what's it what's it like directing
the first time you directed on set for
legends of tomorrow was the first one
yeah first episode cause you directed a
couple right
uh i've done three legends in one flash
jeez
has anyone else in the cast done any or
done more than you um
more no but uh maisie who used to be on
the show she's not anymore she's
directed and then just mcallen as well
as directed
do you have any other actors
i think that was it
how did you feel like the first time i
said were you nervous be honest oh i was
so nervous
it's it's it was quite terrifying um
just because you're not sure what
is
fully expected you or what you know how
to
how everything works um i think the most
nerve-wracking part was always
when it came to blocking
because you're like okay and then
everyone's just you know and you're like
having to communicate with everyone at
the same time you're the director all
eyes are on you what are we doing yeah
and you're trying to explain to the
actors like and hoping to try to if you
have some idea that you you want them to
do and
um so you're especially on legends
there's so many people and
you know i like to design a lot of like
camera movement things i got to know i
got okay
all right
and it just it kind of requires maybe
specific movement from the actors and
the camera and uh
it's kind of like like a dance and and
sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't and um it's just all eyes on you
and
everybody has all all the questions and
you know you're supposed to know all the
answers and
uh it's do you ever say i don't know oh
you think about you you do you you don't
have your ego you put your ego you leave
your ego at the front door i think in
the beginning i was more
uh
i
didn't want to say i don't know because
i didn't
want to people think i don't know what
i'm doing or
yeah i just felt like as the director it
is my obligation to know and like so i
should know um
because it's my responsibility and right
now way more often like especially
notice this time on flash you know with
there was a question it it would be and
i didn't know i would be like i don't
know help me figure this one out or what
do you think
um
and i think that's also really helpful
with with actors too if you say like you
need something or you don't know how to
something's not working but you're not
sure how to fix it and to just be like
i'm not sure how to make this work like
can you help me figure out this and
everybody then is
also kind of then gets to shine a bit
too so people
can offer something that maybe you
weren't thinking of it's also like um
because i got to direct i directed the
feature and i directed an episode of
small and a short as well and
i remember
the one thing i hated as an actor was
when a director came okay so you're
going to be over here and you're going
to be over here and you're going to take
your glass and you're going to walk i'm
like whoa whoa whoa bro
i'm not doing i mean let's let's talk
about this yeah why am i going there
what's my motivation not just because as
a director you up he'll go over there
yeah yeah and actors don't like that at
least i don't some don't give a [ __ ]
someone like put me wherever you want i
don't care
yeah and that's the hard thing too it's
like you it's different for every show
and it's different for every actor how
because some actors are like just just
tell me tell me where to stand like tell
me where you're saying
yeah and like if you get to like it's
like don't stop
just tell me where to stand and then
there's other actors who really want
like the
you know the reasoning behind everything
um
but but yeah i think it's you know like
if you want the actor go over there then
put some prop that you want them to pick
up for something and place it there
whatever it is have you had toughies
um people that you're just like oh my
gosh they don't trust me because in the
beginning when it's your first time
directing like oh katie lots she's
directing or michael rosenbaum he's
directing the episode the other actors
whether they tell you or not are going
huh
can she do this can you do this can do
they have the are they gonna make my is
my performance gonna suffer because
they're not giving me what i need
there's all these things that you're
probably they're probably thinking
yeah
i i think i
had built up a lot of goodwill with uh
the the cast and the crew so
it was it was a friendly set and i think
people you know trusted me
um
already because they they they knew me
right uh there was definitely like i
think it was a little harder with some
of the camera team
um how so
um
if
them feeling like you know what you're
doing and that you are worthy of being
in that position uh or are you just like
an actor that's being appeased and
getting this you know huge opportunity
and it's
not fair um
and people that have been in the
industry for a very very long time and i
think a lot of times too if when you
want to do something different
then
it's
and people have been doing it for a long
time and everything's been done that way
for a long time
it's like that's not how you do it this
is not and it's like
i know but this is why you know i'm here
is so we can do things maybe try
something different and
um
but
it's also it makes sense you need to
earn people's
uh respect
you might not have it right away but
um but then you just earn it
i
i i know what it's like the first time
you direct on an episode of
with other actors that you've been
working with
and i just i i
was not going to do it i was too nervous
like [ __ ] i don't know i don't know if i
could do this
in my head i didn't tell anybody else
i was like you know what i don't need to
prove myself i don't need to do this i
don't need to so i'm starting to do that
and i walk in to the makeup trailer and
steve oben who's the wardrobe guy at the
time wardrobe who i adore
goes
i said something he was like everybody
knows you're not going to direct
everybody knows you're going to not
you're not going to do it
you're going to like you're going to say
[ __ ] it you're like and i go oh really
that's that's what it took it took
someone's disbelief in me
is that the right word disbelief in me
it works all right i'm fine
uh
and i went outside i go you have to do
it now you have to prove to all these
people that you can do it
you know prove it to yourself and i felt
like i there were you know i felt like i
knew how to talk to actors i knew how to
you know get good performances but the
technical stuff you know and you have
this team around you thank god it's not
like you're directing your first thing
and you're like the camera guy doesn't
know me i'm not he's not
he's been doing these episodes
the lighting the makeup all these things
are there for you to make it easier
right
so
then going off and doing your own thing
it's it's a little different because
it's a little raw it's like
you're hiring everybody oh my god it's
so much yeah that that that to me the
whole benefit of working in television
is like
you come on and you just get to be the
director you're not having to produce
and figure out like craft services and
hire all these things it's like you just
go oh i would love to have you know this
prop or this set and then everybody's
like great let's make it happen and like
that team is already put together to
just make those things happen which is
amazing
yeah have you had that moment where
you're just like
as many moments i'm sure as you had were
like oh [ __ ] i didn't i should have done
this i should have done that do you have
do you ever well go answer that you're
gonna answer that oh i mean yeah of
course all the time
i think when is it when does it occur to
you does it occur to you on set
sometimes does it occur to you when
you're watching dailies
um
both
i i don't i don't i'm not a big fan of
watching dailies unless i need to
um
but let the editor call you and say uh
we need this
yeah i mean i usually always have
everything we need it's just sometimes
it's like uh that could have been i'll
think of some a cooler shot later
or a transition or something that i
could have done that i didn't do that i
wish i did um
which and yeah and i think you know part
of it too is like you have to just like
be decisive on things and just keep
moving forward and you don't have a lot
of time um
so that that stuff when you're when
you're rushing and
is is just bound to happen yeah how many
moments do you have where you're like
i'm good i'm [ __ ] good this was a
good moment i was really a good director
today do you have those moments where
you feel very confident very assured
sure of yourself
wow you're really hard on yourself if
you have to think about this you're
incredibly [ __ ] hard on yourself well
i'm just i was trying to think like
uh
yeah i i don't know i i don't know
no
maybe
but i think i'm good at it like i'm not
to be like you do somebody said are you
a good director you'd say yes you
wouldn't hesitate i i think i do have
a like a knack for it i think that what
is it what is it about if you said why
do you say you're a good what is it that
you think why you think you're good
um or have potential to be like you know
uh but we're all working hard you want
to get better and better yeah experience
right um
i think i have a good balance of like
right and left brain
so i i
can
be very creative and and have all of
those things but i also
understand
like getting things done in a certain
amount of time and being efficient and
uh
all the other elements that come with
directing that have are about you know
leading the the team as well um being a
leader on set
so i think directing is very much like
you've got to have both sides uh not
just being creative and not just being
you know logistically figuring things
out it's like kind of having both um
so i think i can have both of those
sides
inside of you is brought to you by magic
spoon i have talked about these guys
quite often uh you know when we're
younger we eat the hell out of cereals
and it doesn't matter because we're
young and our bodies can handle it and
we're not going to get overweight and
we're not going to have all these
negative results right away i mean you
do but we don't care as much when you're
younger but when you get older you're
like i can't do these cereals anymore
all the sugars and the fat and all the
whatever the heck is in there
so
i'm here to tell you that you can have
cereals now you can have beautiful
lovely tasty cereals
and magic spoon provides those
check this out ryan tell us what's in a
box of magic spoon
zero grams of sugar zero 13 to 14 grams
of protein that's not much and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving
wow only 140 calories a serving can you
believe it it's keto friendly it's
gluten free it's grain free it's soy
free it's low carb
build your own box nine available
flavors to build your own very
customized bundle are cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cookies and
cream maple waffle blueberry muffin
cinnamon roll and honey nut i need them
to send me more stuff because there's a
few of these that are new they just keep
you they're so successful now that
they're getting all these new flavors
and i need to test those flavors out
don't you don't you agree i agree
because they sent us some boxes and we
tasted it and we really liked it but i
want more magic spoon i need more
they're like we'll go buy them then okay
well maybe i will and you know what's
even more exciting michael what's that
magic spoon just brought back their
cereal bars they were so popular that
they brought them back permanently yes
it's a perfectly convenient on-the-go
companion for your cereal guys you gotta
check out magic spoon i've said this
before i have had friends text me email
me and say come on is this stuff really
good i'm like yes it is and then they
buy it and they love it and they know
that i'm not lying
go to magicspoon.com
iou to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and be sure to use our promo code iou at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's backed with a 100
happiness happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember get your next delicious
bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou to save five
dollars off thank you magic spoon for
sponsoring our episode
and now a word from our sponsor better
help
one of my favorite sponsors by the way
uh ryan what does burnout mean to you
not like you see these guys that are
burnouts
like that's different well it's
completely different
just uh being
depleted depleted of energy overworked
overworked not making enough time for
yourself yep have you guys felt burnt
out i i know i have i constantly feel
burnt out
it feels to me like
i just don't have energy to do anything
and you know you've got to take time for
yourself you've got to pay attention to
your body your mind and and better help
is there for us ryan i know still uses
better help a lot of my listeners yep
listen to better help
um
life can be overwhelming
it sure can and many people are burned
out without even knowing it symptoms can
include lack of motivation irritability
fatigue and more we associate burnout
with work but that's not the only cause
any of our roles in life can lead us to
feel burned out better help online
therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself i don't know how
many times i say this on the podcast be
good to you be good to yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
um i know
that i get so in my head that i
sometimes don't know what to do next i
don't i'm overwhelmed with life i'm
overwhelmed and i just tend to go back
in the bedroom and just fall on my bed
and try to sleep it off
instead of dealing with my [ __ ]
if i could say that i don't think better
help it cares it's real stuff here i'm
talking about
but um
talking to a therapist talking to
someone someone who's objective someone
who can you know who listen to you who's
a professional it helps it really truly
helps and um
don't take my word for it take ryan's
word for it take
take uh all the patrons and all the
people around the world that use better
help yeah take their word for it yeah
um better help is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy i
can tell you that especially living out
here in california you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours
and our listeners get 10 percent off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside
that's better help better help
dot com slash
inside
do you ever lose your cool
um have you ever just been like shut the
[ __ ] up
yeah oh yeah really
but uh sometimes that to me it's not
even losing cool it's just like what's
necessary in the moment
right if if it's you know like things
are out of hand it's like sometimes you
have to
it's like real things back in and if
doing it like okay guys like okay guy
everybody like isn't working like you
then you gotta
do what works and is it do you find that
you have different
ways of directing to different actors
like oh brandon brandon could take
direction i'll give it to him this way
he could i could be hard on him and he
could just he can go with it this one i
need to coddle a little bit this one do
you find that oh for sure for sure um
it's kind of like two especially the
some some actors want to know why they
you know and they want that explanation
and they want to get into the
the the feelings and all the stuff
behind it and other actors are like
you know just do it because sometimes
too it's like if you need
say you want the an actor to do the line
facing
turn like you want them to do the line
facing this way right because if they
turn over their shoulder like that you
have a whole nother setup you have to
turn around yeah and get that line and
it's going to take you know and you and
if you don't have that time
you need them to say it that way and so
it's some actors you're like hey we're
going to get out of here way faster if
if you play that line forward actors
that kind of know what they're doing
they'll say those things yeah i think a
lot of actors who've been in tv for a
long time uh it's
they
they can rationalize it and do it
themselves easily um other actors do not
want to hear about camera don't do not
it's insulting to be you know like hey
can you throw that line like for this
way for you know it's like
you you need to be like you know i
actually think you know they
you're so mad at them right now they
don't even want to look at them and so
you know it's like don't even like it's
you can't even they don't even deserve
your your eye contact you know whatever
it is it's
there was something i forgot like
oh maybe cindy lemay booker
but there was a direction about
he needed the actress to
uh fire a gun and she was doing it so
quick and it was like couldn't even see
it
but
you could tell that actor like hey
you're going so fast like we can't even
see you so just you know um be up there
slow it down and be up there longer or
you tell the actress like
you need to make sure you really get a
good aim because you can't just fire it
without taking aim so make sure you've
got you know you lock eyes before you
fire and now
that actress instead of being like
boom it's you know she's coming up and
actually has something to do motivation
yeah which is such a gift because that
then you know and if you can communicate
something like that quickly
i think every actor would prefer that
than the
you know just being like camera needs
you longer because then they have to
come up with their own justification but
it's it's sometimes hard to think of a
concise way to say things and so
a lot of times directors if you're like
oh you know because you don't want to
look at that person and you know and
it's too long um but if you can be
concise about everything i think
everyone would always prefer a an action
to you know kind of do
you really love it i could tell your
passion you just like when you're
talking about it when you're
it's it's just you could see it how much
of a passion you have for it i it's cool
i think i
needed the challenge too after being
playing this character for so long
um
sarah lance yeah sarah lance
lance sarah lance sarah lance and i i
needed
to be creatively uh stimulated and
challenged and directing is
incredibly challenging over stimulation
it's i mean it's so much work um so much
work it really is and i think
i'm assuming it gets easier the better
you get because you just
you know you know yeah uh whereas right
now it's like
i really think
everything through um
and so it's just a lot of
and and there's just some little time to
do it too which is hard like
i
just directed an episode of flash and i
got the script the first day of prep uh
so i i read it and then it was like i
had my first meetings for prep and
it's hard because
you get on those meetings and
it's most of prep anytime you're in a
meeting it's mostly for all the other
departments for you to answer the
questions and give you all the
information and so it's like
okay well with this like do you think
you know you're gonna need like how many
like vfx shots do you think you'll need
for this and i'm like i
have no idea i literally just read this
thing right right and so
you you got there's so much and it's
you have to do like all of the work
to know
for me it's like i want to have time to
do think everything through because you
need to know what camera equipment you
want
uh for the type of shots that you want
or the the prop like everything has to
be pre-planned because if you get there
on the day it's like then you don't have
the whatever it is that you need or yeah
you know one of my friends he was a
producer on smallville i remember he
said just give me some direction give me
some insight because he's directed so
many things
greg beeman
and i he says
don't give an actor more than two notes
at a time and i go why because most of
them can't handle it if you start they
start drifting off after the second one
they're they're they're because they're
thinking about the first and second
you're giving them too much information
you're not gonna get it get these two
notes be clear about it just go hey just
two things do this do this
then the next take you could say okay
great and get to that third and fourth
thing it was a great note for me because
i didn't want to over note someone is
that something you had to learn
um
i think in the beginning
i was a bit more
uh
i i had a very specific vision of things
like how i wanted it to be done
and
when you do have that then you have a
lot more notes
because you're trying to shape it into
this thing that you want
and and i think as i started to do it
more i had
less
i would have less notes because i was
more just working
with what they gave and i would
only have things that i more really
needed story wise right um but yeah i
think
it is and some actors can handle uh no a
lot of notes some no none and especially
like with
uh
blocking like if you need like that's
sometimes really hard for people moving
to to places yeah uh while they're doing
things yeah what about directing
yourself
uh
that is
i it's not my favorite to do
uh to act and direct at the same time
because
so much of the work is like done
when you're sitting there behind a
monitor
and and watching like okay i got that
shot i need still need this and ooh that
performance or whatever the camera move
and if i'm on camera i can't see but
they have they can't write you out of a
show they need you in there um well in
the beginning they they wrote me out and
like gave me a lot of time and it was
awesome i think i was like in one scene
in my first episode
and then
this this last one which was for the
100th episode when i directed the 100th
you directed the 100th episode
boy they must really believe in you for
direct 100th episode seriously um that's
pretty incredible it was cool it was i
felt really lucky um but it was
incredibly challenging because i was
working a lot during prep i was in the
episode before and i think maybe because
the one before i was like oh you know
this isn't so bad like i can i could do
this and but
i i lost a lot of my prep timers trying
to prep in between
uh takes on sets and so i just i didn't
get as much time
we had a late script um and it was
really
technically challenging because we had
like
a lot of um motion control stuffs with
with the camera and you know one actor
playing two people i had a scene with
like 16 actors in it
um
it was good lords but but like i don't
like i can't there's not enough time if
i had enough time to go and watch
playback i would love it because i
actually
would prefer
watching myself and i can go
oh my this would be better this is the
beat i'm missing or i could i like that
too yeah and also i'm watching them so
much of
acting is
is with the camera and what the camera
catches and i think in the beginning i
was like to i was very you know like uh
just about being real and
um
[Music]
and even now like i actually watched uh
for i we had
my boyfriend and i were watching mad men
to just see this like 60s you're trying
to for something and you were in that
and and we watched i and i couldn't i
couldn't watch it i couldn't watch it
but
the like just seeing a little bit of it
i was like wow i am completely unaware
of the camera and which also i think is
good
um
i think there is a there is like a
rawness that's that's nice to
to it um
but
there's also things where i'm like it
would be better if you could see your
face and you know things if you're
you're looking down and you're because
you're thinking or you're emotional and
this is where you would be but it's like
no one cares it like you can't see it
right and so maybe that's what feels
real but like this is gonna come up so
much better and yeah
um
i i think i'm
having the
i used to like pride myself on being
like that's just raw and like it's not
about camera and but now i'm like no i
think having the technical
being able to keep that
with a sense of the camera um
is is is better um
inside of you is brought to you by
shopify if you don't know what shopify
is let me just tell you shopify gives
entrepreneurs the resources once
reserved for big business so upstarts
startups and established businesses
alike can sell everywhere synchronize
online and in-person sales and
effortlessly stay informed
shopify is something that i use that's
easy to use that helps me navigate
throughout my merch all the merch that i
have
tells me what's my best sellers tells me
when i'm running out of something uh
it's so easy to use and i don't know
what i would do without them i started
out using shopify and i had like one
product now i have like 30 products i'm
always adding new ones it's easy to use
it's easy to add things
shopify really makes it amazing for
especially for small business owners or
anyone who is starting a business
shopify is there and they've got all the
tools there for you to use to help you
navigate through uh
you know
your
website or whatever your your uh your
merch whatever you're selling uh
shopify is there
believe me like this podcast started out
selling very few things i think i was
selling a t-shirt right
now i'm selling lunch boxes and
mugs and tumblers and t-shirts and i
just it goes on and on and i always
check it i'm always like oh look at that
our sales were up 25 this month why was
that ryan oh that's because i had this
new merch that people like i can see
things in real time and uh that's
shopify like mine shopify powers
millions of businesses from first sale
to full scale reach customers online and
across social networks with an
ever-growing suite of channel
integrations and apps including facebook
instagram tick tock pinterest and more
gain insights as you grow with detailed
reporting of your conversion rates
profit margins and beyond shopify is
more than a store you can connect with
your customers i have done that i have
contact contacted them seeing what works
uh asking your customers helping them
out if something's wrong with an order
you could drive sales manage your
day-to-day
shopify instantly lets you accept all
major payment methods more than a store
shopify grows with you this is
possibility powered by shopify go to
shopify.com
inside all lower case for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
inside right now shopify.com
inside
do you feel
i don't know
the way you talk about directing kind of
makes me feel like you're going to
eventually gravitate towards just
directing and not act do you do you love
acting as much as you used to or you
just you found a new love or you think
you can do both
i think i can do both
um
i always just
follow whatever i'm
curious about like whatever i'm
passionate about it's always led me down
the right roads
um
and i never thought i would be an actor
i didn't
that i'd start
even thinking about it really how old
were you when you started acting
i think it's 22
22 when you started yeah and how did
that start
um
well i
so i came up to la
for dance and i was dancing
um
and
then i moved to germany to be in this
girl group
and
so i was like kind of doing the backup
dancing thing and then i was
uh
in the forefront and then i came back
and because i was like
and the the girls still wanted to do
like the same group but i'm like like
this is not isn't singing is not my gift
to share with the world
um but you could dance and i could dance
um and
and i went on tour with avril lavigne
and like how did that happen how do you
just tour with avril lavigne do you
audition for avril lavigne
so how many girls auditioned for an
avril lavigne video or tour tour tours
are always like
tours are big ones for dancers so you
get you get a lot of people um
i don't i don't know how hard is it how
many
i mean how many do they choose
how many well maybe 20.
like did i go on tour yeah oh not even
close there's like
i don't know four girls and four guys so
you were chosen at the four girls
out of probably thousands
yeah i don't know how many thousands
auditioned for avril maybe uh but did
you like her
um
not particularly really did you not talk
with her much no she was very uh
she wasn't very outgoing right um she
didn't make much effort to to connect
though i i guess i also didn't i've
never been like a
hey let's be friends yeah yeah like so
you feel like it was partly your fault
partly her fault probably no well i
think i mean you've seen pictures where
like she people fans pay like 500 to
take a picture with her or something and
they like have to be like two feet away
have you seen that
only during the pandemic
no i think this was not apparent no no
i'm saying pandemic i can understand two
feet away but um
wow and i just kind of remember thinking
like if you really like do not want to
be around people that much like and
don't want them touching you like
then don't offer photos ops you know
like where you're gonna be like give me
your money but don't touch me
um or maybe there's some who knows i
don't know like who am i to judge what
her reasonings are but that's just your
experience yeah she wasn't particularly
friendly um and there was her manager or
whoever it was at the time
there was like this just drama stuff and
they felt like we were leaking stuff to
the press about
things and it was like
this is and
i didn't want to she didn't want me
another like blonde on stage that i
didn't want to dye my hair so i was like
in a wig and i just was like kind of on
i remember like looking at myself i'm on
tour and i'm you know back up dancing
after kind of more being in the front
and i'm in the back and they're like not
very nice and um have this wig on and at
one point i got an eye infection i was
like my i had like my eye got infected
and i had like a sinus infection and
you're like on a tour bus like this
you're dancing
yeah i had like and it was like i
remember i had to wear like my glasses
because i had contacts and an eye
infection i couldn't and i couldn't not
have my glass like glasses on and so i
was on stage with like glasses and this
big wig and i just was like who am i i
don't even know like this is not me what
am i doing with my life
and and then i came back and that's when
i started taking acting classes and
um because of the bad experience you had
you felt like i want to do something
else well it just wasn't me anymore like
i wasn't this i've it's time for
something new and
um these tours are mostly designed for
younger
people young dancers who have a lot
right so did you feel like i was like
20. so that's pretty young yeah that's
pretty young when you're doing and you
quit probably by the time you were 22
yeah
wow
um did you like it for a while did you
like could you dance with didn't you
go on tour or you did a video for lady
gaga yeah dance with lady gaga i bet she
was cool she was cool i didn't like hang
out with her or anything but she would
come to rehearsals and and
put the work in
and she was like lady gaga all the time
i remember doing the paparazzi music
video and it was like
four in the morning we show up at the
set and she shows up and it's like
she's got like i don't know the you know
she's full out already she doesn't show
up in sweatpants and like go get dressed
and stuff it was like she arrived lady
gaga has arrived you know and she hasn't
even gotten into the lady gaga look yet
so i was like but she's you know and she
she worked hard and she really like
showed up she showed up it was like
um
yeah and i think that actually like
i got called to go on tour with her
and i had just started like my
uh my my two-year meisner program in
north hollywood stanford meisner yeah
and and i was like i can't go on tour
because i am in you know
theater school like
i am
i'm becoming an actor and was your age
like come on what are you talking about
this is a big opportunity come on yeah
cause it was i mean it for as a dancer
it's like that's the top but i look back
at myself i'm like good on you like to
like
have that uh
belief to like turn something like that
down because i was like no i'm gonna be
an actor now like well maybe it's like
that sort of decision making which makes
you a good director you know to be able
to say no i know this sounds so
appealing but it's not right it's not
right right now this is what needs to be
done yeah i need to focus on this
so maybe that was it what was the first
acting gig you got
mad men
that was the first gig you got that's
the big show for your first gig
i remember going on to set and like
you know kind of i had no idea because
my my acting school was not like four
camera there was no
it was like more theater type
uh just learning how to actually act in
the craft of acting and
they and i remember like you know kind
of doing it and then coming back and
there's like all this tape on the floor
and i'm like
like what
like what why why is
why is there tape why is the tape on the
floor
and they're like those are your marks
and i was like oh oh yeah yeah eisner
didn't teach me about marks no no they
didn't no same two where it was like
you know we were drinking or something
and they were like oh you need you drank
on this line and i was like oh yeah but
like
and they're like you need to every time
in the same and i'm like i have to do
every time on the same line because i
was so just like
i'm real and i'm in the moment like
there's no it's a lot it's it's harder
than it looks it's like you have to do
all these things script supervisor keeps
coming at you go yes
you drank at this line hey you walked
over here when he said yes your hand was
open not closed you know and so you're
like okay yeah yeah fingers here and
then like
no like and then you switched it and
you're like god damn it why did i move
so much how about i just the best take
just use [ __ ] that it gets so
frustrating yeah because and you do it
so many times and from all the different
angles and was it something that you but
you did you love it enough obviously you
loved it enough that you wanted to keep
doing it oh i loved it when i was even
studying it i i loved it um what was it
what is it about acting that you really
love
i think i liked
the i i got to feel things i got to feel
everything anything and everything good
or bad and i
i don't not to say like
like i'm an emotional person but i'm i'm
very
i'm pretty in control of a lot of my
emotions in life
and
um can be quite even keeled and things
um and with acting it's like the
i love the up and downs
uh of of getting to feel things that you
might not get to feel in life and in in
a safe place to do it where you're not
like destroying
destroying your life by uh emotionally
losing it um
and i think for me acting always was
the
the my favorite part is when you're when
you surprise yourself and you don't know
what you're doing so like you're you're
in a scene and
some the way you respond is you surprise
yourself and that
being able to like the unpredictability
of that and just the
things like coming up it's like where
did that come from and it's like
that and which is kind of
you know what i learned in
an acting class you're doing scenes like
that all the time
and then when you're you're working in
like television it's rare you get to
kind of
those are very special moments when you
get to have scenes like that do you
still take acting class
you know i i took in uh
i like
my last break i i did
um and then i i want to do another one
um
and i've been actually looking for a
teacher and i've been reading like a few
people's books and trying to find like
what's what feels good because also like
when you start to have your own way i
after i started working and i got back
into a regular scene study class i
didn't like it because
but it maybe it was just this one but it
was very it was competitive and like the
teacher encouraged this like
uh
i don't know competitive competitiveness
um on and off the stage
and you didn't like that no i didn't
like that uh it just it it was like
there was a safe place and then she was
taking away that safe place and
um
and when they tr when when a teacher
tries to like shape you into what they
they want um
but it's like you're you know you need
to always have that humble openness of a
beginner and
you if you close off to like
things you you don't get better but
there's some you can get shaped in a way
that is not you know kind of what you
want so it's like finding that balance
and making sure you're with the teacher
that
helps with that yeah do you get nervous
still do you get nervous auditioning to
get nervous on set playing a character
before you start going is there always
the nerves going or is it something that
you can put aside and just focus on the
work
um
on legends i don't get nervous anymore
uh not at all
acting no
because also it's like i there you you
you
you've got it you you could do it again
and again and you know this character uh
and i know this character um
but auditions yes
and
i think you know when i go on my next
project and i'm playing a different
character i'm sure i'll be
i'm sure every actor is right before
they get a part
they're always nervous as [ __ ] i hear
from the biggest actors
and then once they do a take or
something just get it out
then they could kind of relax but
they're all everybody's the same you
just want to impress you want to be good
you want to be on it and i [ __ ] hate
nurbs
yeah i just want to be
some people say it does it gives you
that energy gives you that drive but for
me it's debilitating sometimes it's too
much
and just ultimately it's like just
[ __ ] listen listen to the other actor
which is something we all forget yeah
but when it comes down to it that's the
number one thing just listen to the
other person
and bounce off that person yeah they
talk about that with improv they talk
about that with acting but i found that
when i'm not listening forget it you're
talking to a
a beginning actor i'm just i could be
really kind of like winging it
but it doesn't seem connected and
sometimes i've had like
i don't i don't know what's going on i
don't know what's going on the other
actor goes are you listening to me and i
go
[ __ ] do another take i got this
just forgetting that i wasn't really
listening i was thinking of my [ __ ] yeah
do you deal with that ever
um
i mean for sure for sure i think we
everybody does um
and i think i'll notice that sometimes
where or you're working with an actor
and it's like they have something that
there is response to what you say and
then like they repeat it but they repeat
it as written not how you said it and
you're like you're not listening not
real
or they or the night before they were in
front of the mirror running their lines
and this is how i'm going to do it this
is how i'm going to say it
and they don't realize by but it changes
by the way you know you respond to other
by responding to what the other actor is
giving you that's why i really like
meisner because it's all about
it's all about that it's the pinch ouch
like
uh nothing
you you don't do anything unless
something makes you do it and everything
is off the other person and i actually i
went into i think it was season six or
something with and i had all my like
acting icons and things on my trailer
wall and you know and it was the whole
thought of all of those things where
it's like you don't do anything until
something the other person makes you do
something and nothing not self-generated
and
and then i the first scene that i come
on and to do they're like okay but like
um
we need your eyeliner tight so like
don't actually look at the actor and we
need to and it was like okay uh and all
of these things that were just stripping
away
everything that you're uh used to doing
or or that make you feel like you're
it's real and it's in the moment and
because so much of acting is where
you're like
okay now i'm there's a dragon and it's
flying and i'm i'm looking at it and
it's like you're not looking at anything
there's nothing actually there and
you're having to self-generate things
and so it can be hard to kind of
keep that balance that is hard
um
especially do you have to deal with a
lot of that on legends like seeing
things that oh this is gonna how it's
gonna be this is gonna be the cgi thing
and you guys gotta react to it and just
trusting is there a lot of that yeah oh
yeah for sure do you hate that
um
yeah
yeah i think so it's just harder it's so
much easier when you have anything even
if like they give a laser pointer
like that moves
is like
thank you so much because it's like
everyone's trying to like have matching
eye lines and in the same with with
directors where like you're like please
talk me through it get give me something
you know i think i would be that guy i
would be like it's just this it's just a
giant dragon in the sky follow that
light and it's
the fire comes out of its mouth and it's
[ __ ] just would you hate that no
that's what you want okay good because i
felt like i was i would annoy you but
some some directors that if they don't
some directors it's and they're like
you're scared
and now and it's like and they're like
don't i don't know true it's it's better
to be like
and you're like
uh have anything anything to react to
right
do you get i want to know this
because no i've never asked this one
anybody like brandon ralph stephen when
you do the multiverse when you do flash
bat woman
um
legends
arrow you get the picture do you do you
get paid for
extra when you go on the flash you get
paid for as an ep it's an episode of an
episode of the flash
so if you're doing an episode of arrow
and at the same time you're gonna do an
episode of the flash their eighth
episode and you're on your 15th you're
getting paid for a full episode on flash
and a full episode on arrow that's dope
yeah how many episodes do you cross over
a year well we don't do them anymore
really you don't i think flash did
something uh this year but the the big
crossovers the other day but how many
did you do would you say crossovers did
you do
well i mean in one year i would there
was one year where i was on arrow flash
legends supergirl and batwoman i think
so how many episodes if you added all
those episodes up
how many would there be so like
smallville let's say there's 22 episodes
but if i did arrow and i did this
ultimately i did 40 episodes of
television
you mean in like a season or in a season
uh i mean this year it was like i didn't
do any other ones but
that that season i however many we did
on legends say it was 16 plus another
five it's you know it does
helps those numbers for sure wow did you
like doing the arrowverse did you like
doing all that stuff crossing over
um
well do i so the crossovers not arrow
crossovers yeah i'm not the most
articulate when it comes to that stuff
the
yeah i i mean it was fun it was fun to
go
on other shows
and see
how their shows work and see the
work with the other actors
for sure but sometimes it sucked because
there's just too many people
and you're like and feeling like an
extra because you're just there and
you're like maybe say one line you know
um but they're fun yeah if you had to
name
your top five actors that you've worked
with
on these shows who would it be who's the
first person to think of you just love
working with it
no disrespect to anybody else you love
everybody but if you just like oh my god
this person has just become a a a real
close friend or i just love there's
something about working with this person
nick nixano
i
he's just like he's just such a gem of a
person
i really like the way i really i just
like the way that
his mind works you know and he's such a
he's just a sweet really sweet person i
really like nick
cool yeah how long is is that will
legends last
well i don't know we don't uh the
they just announced early pickups for a
few of the shows and legends wasn't one
of them
are you concerned or do you do you care
um
yeah i care
it's interesting like
in in the beginning in the first after
like season two or something it was it
was so hard and like pretty
miserable
um
that and i like wanted off i didn't want
to do it anymore why was that
we were literally working 14-hour camera
days almost every single day and they
we were not very well taken care of
um
the it was like la there was nobody from
l.a no writers no producers anybody up
in vancouver so they had no idea what
was the conditions were like on set
and
we had a few actors at the time that
really did not want to be there
um
and
there was everyone in in vancouver
was not in charge they weren't they
they had to just get it done like what
la says to do right and so then the
people that were actually there and
could see what was going on didn't have
the power to change make changes or and
like they were just beholden and so
it and then
there was a lot of like just
it wasn't very good and then the la
started sending people up like a writer
up and
to make that bridge then we got a
producing director um and that helped a
lot
um
i don't remember where i was going with
that yeah
see the pickup
oh and if i wanted it to go yeah exactly
if you wanted to go um but now
it everything is worked out yeah
everything is it's much more um the
working conditions are good all the
relations are good everyone
gets along has a really nice time
um we like the writing a lot uh it's a
family yeah and and we were proud of the
show you know i think there's times too
where we didn't like it was like oh what
are we doing and
we the show is its own identity and it's
you know the writing's good everything
is it's fun um
so i i would love for it to go for
another season because also i think it
sucks to end it like that right um
after so so many episodes and you know
such a long time and cw is you know
historically always told a show when
it's on its last season so that you can
do it justice and and wrap it up and
give it a a proper you know ending yeah
and i i think
everything's there's like you know
there's the cw they're selling the cw so
that's changing things and
um
but i really would love to do another
season to
like
you know end it properly i want it to
and it's cool that you feel like that a
lot of people are like oh we've done
enough we're like you know i'm done at
the end of seven seasons small but i was
like ah yeah what else could i do i'm
done yeah i don't want i want to go off
and do something else i've done this i
did this my contract's over i want to
you know but to say yeah i'm ready to go
back that's that's kind of cool and i i
think too is because i'm directing it
also
it's yeah like
i don't know i want to go back and take
what i've learned from directing on a
different show over there and
i think it's different too when the i
think
tell me every moment i feel like you you
feel like you they respect you
the powers that we respect you and
there's something really
important i mean that's incredibly
important i never really felt that i
just felt like you know you're you're
gun for hire and i just never felt that
love from the crew and cast i did but
from you know i just never felt there's
something so like demoralizing about it
when you don't and that's in the
beginning i felt like that too right and
it's like and and there's just this
feeling of like they're pushing on you
that you have no power and like you are
going to do what we say and it's very
yeah it's that that's not a good feeling
like you said earlier well you just
don't have control mm-hmm it's that you
have no control over what's going on
stephen amell i asked him about you
and what can you tell me about katie she
is the og mask wearer in the aeroverse
the original gangster please tell her to
move to austin what do you mean by that
i i just went to austin actually this
weekend um
i've lived in la for a very long time
now and i mean i'm a socal girl but
i
lately i just been feeling like i kind
of want a change and i want an influx of
like
new
new
people new i i mean i love my my best
friends and most of my friends are here
so that's only hard part but a change of
pace a different atmosphere something
and i want to be a little more removed
from the industry i think like i want i
love the
creating in the industry but i think it
can
become an echo chamber of
of things and less
you know new ideas and new inspiration
um
when you're just in it all the time and
that's all you know right so i've
kind of exploring the idea of maybe like
going on a
some feeling a call to adventure all
right uh lastly this is this is [ __ ]
talking with katie lotz this is these
are the fans okay rapid fire
you just answer them if you don't answer
them you don't have to but this is these
are my patrons i love you guys go to
patreon.com inside of you to become a
patron and support the podcast i
appreciate it get to ask these questions
uh raj what were some of the non-acting
jobs you had to take on while trying to
get your career going uh
as a dance teacher
you were yeah
a dance teacher did you like it
um
yeah i did for how old how old people
were old older no younger younger kids
little kids how older were people older
people younger but i started uh dancing
like in
getting jobs as a dancer when like my
when i was 17. so i was able to
financially support myself through that
mostly um or fully zack p what was has
been your favorite thing about playing
sarah lance
i i mean it's her evolution is so cool
and i think uh
being able to go
go on such a journey with this character
for different things and
um
especially being able to get her like i
loved being
seeing her become happy too is really
nice and uh yeah
i guess the evolution cool michelle k
what's the biggest challenge you're
facing right now
that's a tough that's a great question
michelle kay yeah michelle k
um
i mean i my life's pretty good at the
moment like if you would knock on wood i
i think i went through a really hard
time
as probably most did like at the
beginning of the covet aside from covid
um
and have come out of that much
better than than ever bef before um
so i'm feeling in a pretty good place
but i guess my what's my biggest
challenge
um
[Music]
maybe leaving la
it could be one of them
i don't know that's a tough question
sometimes when questions are really good
i'm like i gotta really really like
think about it and have a good answer
but
i guess on a smaller sense
trying to get some um
schedule like a
routine in into my life
a healthy routine
because i've i've just been so on the go
i'm never in one place for a long like
time
to be able to
get healthy habits and
i'd like that's that's a big challenge
for me right now yeah like what do you
do for your well-being what do you do
are you a big uh advocate for exercise
and activity i mean what is it you do to
keep your mind straight um
so i journal that's like a big one every
morning a journal and for how long
however long i feel like
sometimes i write like a paragraph
sometimes i write like three pages wow
um
but and it's just like dumping things
but i think
i i think it's really important to take
some time to reflect on your life
and and think about your life because
if not it'll just go
in a direction
and you have to take aim like you have
to
curate your life uh and i think
journaling is something that really
helps me
feel like i'm
active in being a creator of of my life
and
how it's going and and who i am and i
think a lot of times we just get
swept up in in the momentum of things
and the next thing you know it's like a
year has gone by and or 10 years or 10
years and
have you done what you wanted to do or
are you
you know going in a direction you want
to go are you the person that you want
to be
and
that was a big one for me learning when
i was going through that hard time is
like the
if you you can be whoever you want to be
like just start doing the things that
that person would do
like you want to be the person who works
out every day then just work out every
day like just do it like start doing it
yeah um
yeah it takes one step at a time it
sounds so cliche but like you have to
start somewhere it sounds so
overwhelming when you're like i have to
do this i have to lose weight i have to
do yes if you think about the whole
thing
but tomorrow or right now
do it go for a walk dude it's those
little things that just add up add up to
get you where you want to go small
manageable goals yeah but you just do
them and like
the more you do them them like the
smaller things you're like oh okay and
then you're proud of yourself you feel
good about yourself you know you feel
good about who you are and that gives
you more strength to do even more things
last question uh nico what do you
consider to be your acting uh role model
who
whose career you'd like to emulate a
little bit
first person that comes to mind
charlize uh charlize theron
so i might say even saying her life yeah
charlize throne yeah
strong woman too
very strong yeah
and does like a nice mix of big
blockbustery things and also like
incredible
indie
um
indie films are you gonna direct
features do you want to direct features
mm-hmm that's what you want to
transition into that
i yeah i think there's uh
a creative freedom and like that you get
in a total world building that you you
get to do
with with a film and and the time to
like
really really like craft and curate it
um and have that yeah control control
control
what song was that who sang that janet
control you don't know that ryan janet
jackson that's cause he's really young
although you're young yeah but janet
jackson yeah janet jackson it's the
mustache right i think it's the mustache
she just trimmed it i know florence
welch we could talk about that yeah
i know her uh this has been great thanks
for being so open and honest and just
really cool i mean i had a really good
time talking to you this is cool yeah
thanks yes
thanks
there you have it another episode in the
can and again i hope you enjoyed it
again if you really liked this episode
and you enjoyed listening to katie i
urge you to stick around next week give
the podcast a chance we're always trying
to get new listeners new people to come
on board and uh spread the word spread
the gospel if you will you know it's
important so again our handles are at
inside you podcast on instagram and
facebook and at insideyoupod on the
twitter
um brian you got anything going on
i mean i'm just traveling a lot finally
you are traveling a lot yeah you're
going to be exhausted i am are you going
to be grumpy when you come back
i hope not yeah i hope not either i hope
i get a little uh get a little respite
get a little clarity see a little
different part of the world that's not
my apartment yeah you're going to
ireland
uh not not yet not yet not yet uh
yeah france
england
spain
wow trying to pack it all in in one pack
it all in it might be too much fun that
might be too much fun yeah i think
you're gonna have a great time but i
think you are gonna be exhausted about a
week into vacation i'm kind of like i
want to go back home i just want my bed
i want clean clothes
i want
a hamburger
i just want my own [ __ ] you can get that
anywhere yeah i guess well you sort of
can almost anywhere it's probably a
parisian a parisian um
uh hamburger is probably expensive
but it's tasty though that's tasty i'm
not french bread
[Music]
hey check out the inside of you online
store if you want some cool merch we got
funko pops of lex luthor and scripts
signed and
lunch boxes signed by tom welling and
myself and a bunch of other stuff
tumblers inside of you merch blah blah
and i forgot to say in the
well maybe i did because we'll do it
again but join patreon um my lovable
patrons uh if you go to patreon.com
inside of you they uh support the
podcast in many ways there's different
tiers i send merch boxes blah blah blah
check it out i'll send you a message
after you join uh
patreon.com inside of you
so i think we should get right into it
we should get into the top tier patrons
stuart let's do it ryan let's do it here
we go give them shout outs
nancy d leah sarah v little lisa yukiko
jill e bryan h i just saw brian h at the
uh omd concert i went to a concert omd
orchestral maneuvers in the night i
touch you once i touch you twice i got
the shirt on you got the shirt and i saw
brian h good to see you brian nico p
robert b jason w kristen k raj
c
joshua d c j
p jennifer n stacy l jamal f janelle b
kimberly e
uh mike eldon supremo 99 more ramirez
san diego m chad
d
w w is correct we and p myopie maddie s
belinda and chris h dave h sheila g brad
d ray h tabitha t tom and liliana a
talia m betsy d hi betsy hi chad l
rochelle marion megkay trav
hell dan
um
i don't remember
l
close
m closer n yes it's dan n
big stbw angel m rhiannon c corey k
super sam dev nixon michelle a jeremy c
andy t cody r gavinator david c john b
brandy d voor
voor i met you vora
i met yavor at vorady khan
sweet man
yvore it was a pleasure meeting you met
him at a convention
camille s the c joey m willie f david h
omar i design otg our good friends
eugene and leah chris p nikki g cory
nicole patricia heather l jake b
james b bobbitt
joshua b tony g megan t mel s orlando c
john b caroline r rob e paul c christine
s
yes yes yes
yes yes christine yes
christine
i think you just want to keep saying it
sarah s eric h spring jennifer r shane
shane spelled s-h-a-y-n-e i've seen it
shane r emma r mark m germain jeremy v
andrew m robert g and
this is a difficult one
z-a-t-o-i-c-h-i-77 a new one
uh
zatuichi
satoichi
77.
if i messed your name up i apologize but
i love you you're awesome we'll figure
it out we'll figure it out we'll get
there i'm sure you'll send me a message
saying this is how you pronounce it but
i mean how the hell would i know how to
pronounce that but i'm glad you're with
us
uh again thank you for listening to the
podcast i hope you enjoyed it today i
don't have too much to say i felt like
today in today's podcast it just it was
you know it's just like hey let's get
into it let's do it
let's listen i hope you enjoyed it
um and i know some people say oh you
seem a little like you i don't know
there's you didn't have much to say you
weren't your jovial self
but i i am i'm just a little tired i
went to that concert last night and i
just feel like let the episode speak for
itself you can't be on all the time you
can't be me
it's hard to be i mean could you imagine
though if i was just like this hey um so
ryan um
yesterday i was
i don't think anybody would want to
listen if they heard me like that so
that's why i pick it up a little bit see
that's why i talk like that that's why
okay you know i am me i am myself damn
it i love you guys thank you for
allowing me to be inside of each and
every one of you thank you for um
choosing our pocket our podcast inside
of you with michael rose's mom as your
podcast this week continue to listen
follow uh
and i thank you from myself michael
rosenbaum in the hollywood hills of
california
i'm ryan tez over here also in hollywood
hills california
that's correct a little way for the
camera ryan hey guys be good to
yourselves please be good to yourselves
you are all you've got really at the end
of the day
all right we'll see
[Music]